okay miss I gotta ask you you
instagrammed about a special someone and
what has his support meant to you
because that Instagram was so sweet you
said he's making you tea what does his
support mean to you in all this it's
really really nice to have that support
I mean I have my family my mom and
brother here with me and then to have
Chanda here as well it's really funny
because every night I'll come home it'll
be like okay let's get the ice let's get
a cup of tea and let's get you food it's
kind of this checklist and I think that
that love and support is just it's
something that we all we all need in
life we need those people to keep us
going and I have the best family I don't
know how I got such a gorgeous family
but somehow I did and I feel very very
lucky
I mean so date nights have become him
taking care of you is that what it is in
LA all right young man you go home yeah
everybody bye bye seven all right give a
tea get the ice I saw I saw 20 minutes
inside yeah it's like that
we got like 20 minute here's a time at
20 minutes on 20 minutes off are you
protective older brother Inge a little
bit here yeah you know I got four
sisters yeah I got five sisters here so
you know I'm yeah let me tell you my
brother mechanic